he's one of our favorite from the world
of hoops and the NBA ABC on ESPN and NBA
analyst or ESPN on ABC NBA analyst Jeff
Van Gundy how are you Jeff
yeah good did you say dr. Gupta said
closing schools doesn't help well he
said that they may learn again that kids
can pass the virus on but it's not
likely is what he said it might not be
as beneficial as we've learned is what
he said and we'll know in a matter of
days not weeks is what he said wow
that's interesting because my daughter
is in high school and they shut down
today they have spring break next week
and then they are going to virtual
learning the following week so they're
going to be off you know about 17 days
from the campus and you know they don't
have any reported cases or anything
right
yes I'm just interested in you know what
that looks like and how much it can help
you know exactly and we're all we're all
starving for information which is why
you know you know we put dr. Gupta on
the air and also just trying to get as
knowledgeable as possible because this
changes so fast so quickly I honestly
thought when the you know when the
Golden State Warriors to follow their
local rule that they could not have fans
in their arena I thought okay that's the
way the NBA is gonna go and then Rudy
Gobert shows up to an arena and test
positive for coronavirus and then they
got to stop another game because an
official that did one of his games the
night before is in New Orleans I thought
wow now my eyes are totally open to this
thing I wonder what you thought in
Sacramento pardon me that they canceled
that game my eyes were totally open I'm
wondering what you thought you know so I
went to see my parents in Florida and on
Tuesday we were at a spring training
game and on Thursday by Thursday when I
came home there's no more sports in
America I mean that's how quickly it
changed and you know everything from
watching a conference tournament game
with them on one night
to a a game being stopped in the Big
East tournament at halftime it's just
it's mind-blowing how quickly everything
changed and so clearly the NBA made the
right decision right I mean how do you
think coaches and everybody else we're
thinking about it throughout the week
and you walk me through whatever you
knew or well I think you know first of
all I think you know everybody uses the
term perspective so often but I think
most coaches most players front office
owners I think they do have it in the
right perspective it's how they earn a
living it's a job they like to do but it
pales in comparison to bigger society of
societal issues like a pandemic so the
coaches I've talked to you know they
have no doubt that the NBA did the right
thing and they also have no doubt that
this could change and go on for even
longer so I don't think they're feeling
bad for themselves I think most people
in sport right now and I think most
Americans are what can we do to help and
I it's why that's where Kevin Love
stepped in and in a manner that
obviously we also heard Mark Cuban step
in to make whole best they can all the
arena workers who work are on hourly
wages and to make sure that they are
made whole while this stoppage of play
continues Jeff yeah it's very it's such
a challenging situation so you know
players have their own contractual
issues that owners could invoke to do to
a pandemic right and and but the real
people or the people that are really
hurting are you know so many of the
people that have to report to work to
get paid and it's not just in the sports
arena it's in the construction area I
mean it goes on and on and on
so yeah you feel for these people
because they need this money they need
this
to live check to check week to week
month to month and you know Kevin Love
very magnanimous as was Mark Cuban and I
think more and more owners will try to
do the right thing it's to what extent
you know if are are they willing to go
and for how long because while we say 30
days in the NBA right now I think that's
going to be an evaluation period it
could go on a lot longer the season you
know there's no guarantees that we come
back and so for this season so I think
you know I think a lot of people are
going to try to do a lot of right things
but there's still so much to be figured
out and so much unknown to deal with
yeah I mean this is a total unknown I
mean I could see there and ask you if
you ever been anything through anything
like this we haven't there's been
nothing I like this so there's no
playbook there's no rulebook there's no
there's just just I guess in a way
fumbling for the light switch and I just
thought it was a honestly the Rudy
Gobert testing was for me the most
shocking moment and it's not because
it's somebody you know famous or
whatever since Tom Hanks announced he
had gotten it before but it really was
you know a moment for me where I
realized how this can cascade so fast
and I think it's dawning on Gobert who
instagrammed out an apology today and it
looks like Adam silver is gonna reach
out to make him or or facilitate him
being part of a public service
announcement about taking this seriously
that's what it looks like Jeff right and
so what was start to me was the doctor
of Oklahoma City running out onto the
court just minutes before a game started
right I mean I think having people in
the arena and right before tip-off they
decide to postpone due to this and
listen Gobert acknowledged his reckless
acts but
we have to remember how young these
people are and how immune they believe
themselves to be to some of these things
and yeah he should of and could have
done it better but he can help to
educate now and I thought his apology
through social media struck just the
right tone he didn't try to you know
dodge his behavior or how Cavalier he
was with the whole situation and wants
to help and I think Adam silver can
really I think he can help a lot of
people by having Gobert follow-through
with a PSA and I also think you know I'm
interested in how Donovan Mitchell feels
and how quickly he can get by maybe Joe
bears recklessness putting him in
jeopardy and his teammates in jeopardy I
think that's another interesting sort of
subplot to the whole thing but I think
oh bear took took the right first step
by just acknowledging what he did wrong
there was no excuse for it and he wants
to help in any way possible going
forward before I let you go Jeff Van
Gundy I'll ask you a question I asked
both Jay Bilas and our number one in
Michigan State's Tom Izzo and our number
two I'd love to get the perspective of
somebody from the next level the the
idea that Geno Auriemma threw out
yesterday upon the announcement that the
NCAA tournaments for men and women's
basketball had been canceled
that seniors should get an extra year
the the seniors right now that they're
their senior years should not end like
this if they so choose to get another
year of eligibility I wonder what you
think of that idea I think it's a
reaction in the immediate aftermath of a
disappointing thing that occurs in these
young people's lives and I feel
for all the college athletes it's not
just the Division one athletes it's the
division three and two tournaments or
going on you know you have spring sports
that have just gotten off the ground
that now they won't be able to compete
in their senior year and while I
understand the idea behind giving them
an extra year and I wouldn't be opposed
to it I also think one of the things
you're constantly trying to teach young
people is stuff happens in life and bad
stuff happens in life and it's not what
happens to you it's what you do next and
so if the NCAA ultimately decides not to
do or the giving the extra year of
eligibility back to these you know I
think spring sports is different than
winter sports because they didn't
actually compete in the get a chance to
compete in those sport I would have no
no problem with the NCAA no it's a bad
thing we feel badly but you need to move
on and deal with it and for the spring
sports I understand why there may be an
exception granted for that because they
didn't get a chance to even play their
regular season Jeff thanks for the time
stay safe be safe be healthy and I hope
we get you back on in April and we'll
talk about an NBA star basketball yeah I
look forward to it I appreciate the time
though today thanks for the call be well
your family - you bet that's Jeff Van
Gundy